[Music]
okay everybody so this is my
spoiler-free review of the northmen
robert edgar's newest film that he
directs and writes and co-written by
shone now i am an absolute super fan of
the witch his first film and that to me
was basically a masterpiece and i really
really loved the lighthouse not as much
but i still thought it was a great great
film
so he's become one of my favorite
directors he is in that re aster
category for me where they're just on
the rise and they're getting the respect
they finally deserve however you get a
little worried before this film came out
because then i see that one of my
favorite horror directors is doing now
an epic right this revenge tale and it
makes you worry little because you're
like okay are we going to lose some of
that great heart he usually does is it
going to kind of box him in that it's a
revenge tale and because revenge shows
sometimes can get a little eye rollie
where it just keeps a lot of grunting
and a lot of you know hell bent on
vengeance and not much thinking to it so
that was always a worry for me from the
start and it's cool that he's getting a
bigger budget it's interesting now it's
focus features as a studio instead of
a24 so it's just this bigger thing all
around but does bigger usually mean
better in my opinion most of the time no
a lot of the times that just makes the
script suffer and if we look at it
through the career of robert eggers i
think that
this film it is obviously looks the best
out of any of these films it has the
most action to it it's brutal and it's
the same cinematographer from both of
his films so similar cinematography
that's still amazing the score stands
out the most and everything in that
facet of it is great and
it's
really well done in that sense and if
you really like revenge flicks and you
like you know game of thrones even it's
very game of thrones you feel like at
the end of the day with this film that
you just watched a solid episode of game
of thrones now why that's disappointing
to me is because
he puts horror into this revenge flick
which i like it's this epic viking story
right i like that he's putting in his
style still but you'll see certain
critics say oh but it didn't affect you
know him being robert eggers i totally
disagree on that because what makes
robert eggers so great is that his
stories are always incredibly smart and
you're thinking about the film for a
long time after and they all end on a
you know haunting moment that stays with
you it just gives you that feeling and
you know what i'm talking about if
you've seen his previous films that
doesn't happen here this is actually a
movie like most revenge tales you can
shut your brain off and that's
incredibly disappointing for robert
eggers and that's where my
disappointment this film comes is in the
story where it's not this incredibly
smart story like his other two films and
you're not going to be thinking about
this movie afterwards you're just going
to watch it say that was a pretty good
time i'm entertained but it just feels
like a really good blockbuster and
i think that that's good but when we
know who's directing it it's
disappointing so you have to look at it
in different ways where i think so many
people like the film i really enjoyed
the film and i thought it was a really
really good film like i was entertained
the whole time i wasn't bored and like i
said production design is off the chart
score is incredible here acting's great
right you got this a-list cast but
before we get into the acting for a
second i do want to make that point that
still though that is where you can add
all this big stuff in a bigger budget
but again yes what the fear was of what
i originally had that he was going to do
an epic revenge tale that was gonna
maybe box him in from doing his ultimate
high ceiling where he can go places
where your brain didn't think you could
go from film and something that sticks
with you and it just doesn't happen here
and guess what if you're waiting for
that classic robert eggers like you know
shot to end the movie that like makes
you feel like wow like no like this
isn't that movie that people are going
to go on reddit and talk about for days
and you know have something that's
making your brain stimulated it's just
not it and that's disappointing yeah so
that fear that i felt when he signed up
for this there you go like i just don't
think it was the best decision for him
to do it you know maybe business-wise
yes it's the best decision but for the
art yeah no it's just like it seems like
he's just having fun making a really
good epic revenge show and if that's
what you're looking for from him that's
great but for me it's just disappointing
to know what he's actually capable of
and then seeing him kind of doing this
so he's really good at it though you
know and it it's that feeling that
visually everything here feels unique
and different that's where it stands out
but the story beats right you've seen
before the message you've seen before
you know it's the blend of game of
thrones the revenant it's those type of
stories that
in a film you know you know where it's
going from the beginning there's a twist
in it that's okay you know it's the
twist we've seen before and then the
message has been done to death so that's
where i was just shocked how unoriginal
those parts were and that's the problem
a lot of tales it could be in any
timeline when it's a revenge story a lot
of times it it's so hyper focused on
that that it doesn't even give a moment
to breathe for character and a lot of
side characters are very thin and that
happens here too and i think
the acting's amazing right you got this
great cast with alexander scarzard anja
taylor joy willem dafoe who i wish was
in the film more bjork who's in here for
five minutes nicole kidman was pretty
good but i've seen her do better and the
standout for me was actually clay's bang
who i wasn't familiar with he played
dracula recently he was actually
excellent in this film so i thought he
actually found the best performance i
think if you're a huge ani taylor joy
fan like me the character is not great
here for her it's kind of just feels
like
not much to her character and she
doesn't really get some great moments
here it's really the alexander skarsgard
show at the end of the day and he does
an awesome job with it and i think he
was perfectly cast for the part but
again you get
little drizzles of horror which is
awesome that we know from robert eggers
but you're gonna take away the thinking
part of it now it's you're removing it
for really intense action ago which is
cool and i love that stuff too
but it's so hard to review something
like this because you know who's behind
it you know what they're capable of and
you know what you're watching and where
it kind of feels limited so
overall though i'm gonna give this film
an 8.1 and it would be my least favorite
of his films but i still think it's a
great movie that you have to see in
theaters because
it is literally made for that it's so
big and intense and
i just think that you gotta accept i'm
going to see robert edgar's movie to
shut my brain off which feels weird and
that's why again like what's bringing
the score up for me is the acting the
music and the cinematography which is
just on point again and the action is
really good but
what's bringing that down is
the script the unoriginality of the
script and of course not having it make
you think at all and you don't feel much
from this film and it's ultimately not
memorable so
giving it an 8.1
let me know if you plan on seeing this
film i'd love to hear your thoughts i
try to respond to as many as i can
please let me know your thoughts on
robert egger's films as a whole i'd love
to hear your thoughts on the witch the
lighthouse and please make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss my spoiler
review that's going to come out soon for
the same film the northmen and please
follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and i'll see you next time